welcome to this video playing am Scott
y'all okay and oh jeez jack okay we
don't get the lenses are in Scott who is
that actually is there nope that was
wrong okay we don't don't learn its name
taking an e5 that's interesting yeah
this is a risky decision because of the
week c5 porn but let's see what happens
I see now if I go Bishop back to back to
h5 is got e6 coming home and taking us
not really in my interest
now it's not that bad but not exactly
what I plan to do yep that was to be
expected but it's not as one-sided as it
may look FD for him the c5 pond is what
I meant with one side that can be a
problem but I have half counterplay
ideas quite clear once actually night to
divorce one of them but you can go back
anyway let's start Bishop e7 or yeah
let's go guess we should be Sam can
always go to deform no need to rush here
I'm not sure I've c4 was so timed well
that the position looks totally fine for
black I think that d 4 square was just a
nice compensation for c5 and it's not
that quick and I mean be three huh okay
maybe here so that Bishop development
gets even more tricky tricky yeah more
tricky as wrong i think but yeah let's
see what he comes up with and I also
caught up a bit on time I am okay so but
if I go Queen a 5b 394 quindi one then I
guess night c2s Bishop g2 unfortunately
just about
but if i take and play between 8-5 b3
and I'm taking here the night deform or
look at the age is also a good move look
the aid
huh look the a torque or 94 let's go
update
now i have looked it too if he goes
let's say query Bishop e3 yeah I this
move I still have hope t2 even yeah
let's play that first and then think
about it even Queen take some a force an
interesting move sacrificing the Queen
it's probably a bit much I'm always
tempted by ideas like that just I think
not quite working it's not far off
okay so taking c6
cheer wonder I mean I do really really
need to cover that do I get my queen
activated somehow hmm
yeah my time my time is ticking ticking
down here huh weird probably missing
some opportunity yeah I missed that move
simply blundering that stuff staring at
it for such a long time and then
blundering this is nonsense yeah and it
was a nice position really
now at least that knight on d4 is some
bit of a nuisance before as a good move
though yeah I know he finds good moves
time morning
takes Bishop takes and threatening 92 I
mean it's not you can take on c5 with
the night wouldn't be that bad actually
technically he's attacking me six so 92
it's not really that big a deal okay I
can't go rook to you one as well so now
d 1 is the strongest probably
just running into bishops III well
that's very very stupid stuff there was
a nice position I really like that hard
to believe that shouldn't be okay there
um yeah cannot go anywhere with that
bloody piece and I can just take your
five probably and win multiple ways
rookie folk winner one mate that's the
cheapest trick ever by its as i can i
can hardly call it a trick okay so
where's that button here black resign
yeah i was embarrassing and it was such
a nice position here so
the engine likes white instead
surprising I mean I thought the only
question is how much god Jeff now maybe
not taking and play 94 here maybe I mean
this is this is saving him otherwise
Nancy to was already winning stuff but
Bishop to Bishop b2 does work and how
the engine gives gives night f5 back
it's completely useless at that line so
maybe look the 18 yeah maybe that really
isn't good I mean Queenie form is got g4
as well I probably have to do this
now it's trapped it's really trapped so
I really made a mistake there
now the engine wants to do this and then
f5 it's interesting
the clear voltage for black which is
kind of difficult to grasp knight on d4
yeah I mean I cannot be worse here with
the knight on d4 I would be very weird
we really weird sure but probably that
was just bad or maybe then here I don't
know it's with three a bit mysterious
probably this is not a good idea because
it gives him that Queenie for move
rookie to assist absolutely leading
nowhere I absolutely did not see that
idea so obviously i mean i blundered
that later this means that rook t2 is
just yeah if you want them kind of a
useless a demonstration it's just doing
not not much still how time to believe
that I'm worse in that position that
really the case with the night or 2d for
this is this kind of thing this is what
the the engine is given and 0.74 wired
hmm
yeah maybe what is better because I'm
not really i don't really have anything
that I can do from here I'm just staying
basically and white might be able to
regroup that night or get to a position
where you can take on default somehow
get me to take with the pawn I don't
know it's kind of I'm kind of irritated
that this should be better for why how
does it continue the slide just for just
for curiosity with this with Lewis Lomu
so say I mean I a six is kind of
debatable at okay night here and now
with this and this yeah so if I just
shuffle let's say it will go there I and
now it gets tricky it really gets tricky
okay here's even the tactic
yeah that makes it difficult he's young
he gets his getting lots of pressure on
that night and I cannot really move it
away i mean i can move with a way but i
have to avoid running into Bishop f5
that's very interesting i really miss
already OOP miss evaluated to that
position tremendously I'm a natural
optimist I know that I tend to believe
I'm better when it's just equal but I
honestly did not think that this should
be any good for wide but ok it's it's a
it's an optical illusion here bishops
III will kick the be sure the the rock
back and he's not that uncoordinated
it's amazing that he takes he force was
bad okay thanks for watching guys